new world order new world order new
world order so the traditional media's
up for their usual shenanigans this time
instead of just going after PewDiePie
again they're going after actress Jamie
Lee Curtis the star of the upcoming
Halloween sequel Paulo in the title of
this article is Jamie Lee Curtis wields
firearms and new Halloween movie is
fight advocating for guns now before I
even get into how idiotic that is it
didn't anyone ever teach you how to
capitalize words in a title like the
title of your article here let me go and
fix that for you second point how is
this news like what points you trying to
make with this she's an actress in a
movie the whole point of acting is to
act like you're the character I honestly
don't know what he's trying to say with
this article all right Louise copy I
know let's take a look at your art
Jamie's got a gun in the latest
Halloween or even I will give you points
for the clever pun but your only one
sentence in and you already found what
you don't know what you're talking about
you're making it sound like she's never
wielded a gun in a movie before they
even in the Halloween movie she's using
on the floor like an h2o and I believe
in Halloween too as well so why are you
bringing it up now what about this is
newsworthy and also he calls it a reboot
it's clearly not a reboot it's a sequel
I mean you can even watch my things you
missed episode where I distinctly
explained the Halloween timeline if
you're unsure about it it's not even
just a little mistake he calls it a
reboot twice in the article and he
basically goes on to write that Jamie
Lee Curtis made some tweets calling for
gun safety and and then goes on to say
that she uses guns in the movie which
again I don't understand what the
writers point to it it almost seems like
he's trying to say that she doesn't
deserve to be in the movie because she
doesn't support gun if that's what
you're going for then you're no better
than those people from last year who are
all Charlotte Johanssen can't play a
cyborg you know
because she's not Asian everyone knows
that all robots are Asian it just seems
like somebody took that concept and
applied it to even more ridiculous level
how dare you let Nick castle play
Michael Myers hasn't anyone noticed that
he's not an immortal serial killer
the other thing that comes to mind that
Luis may have been trying to get across
in his article is the idea that Jaime is
like somehow a hypocrite because she's
making all this noise on Twitter about
gun laws but then she's going starring
in a movie and basically glorifying gun
usage and making like : stuff which
again would be a lot more valid of a
criticism if movies were real but what
Luis may not realize is that movies are
not real they're dramatis sized events
recorded on camera
now if Jaime's Lee Curtis had been on
Twitter calling for the ban of prop guns
than yes that would have been
hypocritical wouldn't it the last time I
checked nobody is upset about prop guns
so as far as the Internet reaction to
this goes pretty much everyone had a
similar reaction what I had making jokes
about how the actors in the movies
aren't actually the characters in those
movies like how Mark Hamill doesn't
actually know the ways of the force
Daniel Radcliffe being called Harry
Potter and Harry Potter films despite
being Daniel Radcliffe it honestly feels
like that's what some people want for
movies to contain no acting and you're
only allowed to be on camera if you're
portraying your exact life of combat
point so basically they want movies to
be YouTube bloggers but without the
suicide forest and fake breakup videos
rain causing wet streets yeah this one
pretty much sums it up it would have
been a completely valid tweet if it
wasn't posted by a hurry I'm kidding but
what I find interesting about this
article is the last line where it tells
us that Halloween hits theaters October
19 it's like he's saying oh I know I was
just attacking this movie a minute ago
but don't forget to support it in
theaters when it comes out in fact I
wouldn't put it above Universal the
marketing team getting together and
saying all right we need some traction
for this movie that none add controversy
works pretty well for Warner Brothers
what kind of dirt do we have on our
female lead and then they found nothing
so they basically just paid Louise $300
and some lucky cheese tokens to write
this trash article I was almost hesitant
to give this dead talk actually because
I feel like I might be playing right
into their hand
because they want to get people talking
about it but then ultimately I decided
if I get a lot of views on this video
then who's really playing into whose
hands I mean I guess to be both would be
but anyway let me know what you think
about all of this is this article real
is it fake is Luisa actually some kind
of cultural genius and I just can't see
it let me know in the comments and if
you haven't seen my things you missed
episodes I'm the two trailers for
Halloween then I'll leave those up for
you in the end cards and be sure to
subscribe to Suzie's world for new
Horrors every week ring that death bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one assuming we both survive
you
[Music]
you